From Advocacy to Innovation: How JS Developers
will shape the future of Internet Security,
[Applause]
AMELIA: Thank you.
Thank you, hello?
Is this - is this on?
All right.
Well, thank you so much for coming out, especially
after we drank all the beer last night.
Today I will be talking about how JavaScript
does/can change the way that we build tools
and how they already are.
And this is probably not news to any of you
all.
So my name is Amelia Abreu, and like Charlie
graciously introduced me I am a design researcher,
and I've always been obsessed with categories.
I'm a Cuban American from Texas, who has lived
in the northwest for most of my adult life,
so it's hard sometimes to answer the question,
"Where are you from?"
And I would like to start out with a point
that categories and distinctions matter and
this is probably not news to JS devs, after
all language without classes, like requires
imposed classifications.
Yes, so today I'm going to talk about distinction
and classification, why these little things
matter, share some of my notes and observations
from working on development and security tools
over the past few years and make an argument
that there's a lot at stake here and that
we can do better and we need to do better,
from a useability standpoint I always say
that usability like security is best bigged
in early on and as full stack JS reaches more
and more momentum, it's more important to
think about this.
So who am I and why am I talking about this?
I'm a design researcher and I will speak a
little bit about how I hate the word "user".
I would never describe anyone I respected
as a user, but the term user experience seems
to have stuck to this area, and over the past
few years I've been working more on security
and engineering tools, and as a result I've
interviewed a lot of developers and worked
with a lot more, and I often find that my
relationship to the Deaf community is a little
bit anthropological and prior to this I worked
in Seattle and before that I was a librarian
and my first career was as a music writer,
and when I look back on these various threads,
the thing that these all have in common is
that they all involve listening to people
talk about complex and technical subjects.
And this ongoing interaction with classification
and systems.
I also want to note that something that has
shaped me is that I am a child of the 1980s
Texas hardware boom.
My grandfather worked for Texas Instruments,
my mother was a mainframe operator and neither
of these were glamorous jobs but they definitely
shaped my understanding of how - the pecking
order of hardware and software and obviously
we are living in a much different round these
days.
So first I am going to talk about distinction,
and taste classifies, and it classifies the
classifier.
So there was a study on thousands of folks
and it was found that their interests reflected
not only economic status but also cultural
status so if you like Petula Clarke that puts
you at a very middle brow status but if you
like shopping at the flea market that puts
you in this square of artistic producers and
cultural capital, and this is something that
I think we can think about in less of a stratified
way but in a way of thinking: okay, the way
that we work, the way that we are, aesthetics
matter and they say a lot about us Bordieu
also will matched this to the foods that we
like to eat and then a gastronomic magazine
classified this so where your pickles come
from says a lot about you.
So in the past few years I have been working
a lot on developer tools and the term developer
experience has come about, and I like it okay
because the word user, or as Laurel says "that
demeaning little word user", is not something
you would use to describe someone you respected.
I would call a friend's bad boyfriend, "Oh,
he is a user", so how do we bring more of
that sense that we are working with folks
to build tools that they can use, tools that
they will integrate into their everyday lives
and everyday work, and that as developers
we will be using whatever is at our disposal
to build better things for the end user, or
for someone else down the line?
There's not really a good nomenclature for
that.
If anyone has any suggestions, feel free to
bring them to me after the presentation.
Yes, so how does one do this?
I find that this is something that is often
mysterious.
I work a lot with ethnographic interviews
which means I will bring the team that I'm
working with into the field to go hang out
with the people who will use the products
that they are building, and I always say that
I'm going to write a book about doing user
research that is asking dumb questions over
and over.
I will often ask people what seem like very
obvious questions and then just listen, and
that takes a lot of humility and also patience
but when we do come to users with little expectation
and little assumption, that's where we can
learn the most about work patterns, about
needs, about work-arounds.
Yesterday's presentation - it blows my mind,
it's blanking me because I'm jet lagged but
there was a really great explanation about
work-arounds in a presentation yesterday that
I loved.
And for devs it's often hard to distinguish
between what about the users of your product
are going to be different than you and your
team and I always like to start with this
question: well, what text editor do you use?
Because if you are using Emacs you will have
different keyboard shortcutting and different
usage patterns than say someone using VIM.
And this is often an issue when it comes to
developer tools because they often come out
of a roll your own solution.
I automate something in my job; I share it
with my boss; I share it with my team.
We say, "Oh, let's bring this to the greater
public".
This onion you see here, this comes from a
framework called cognitive work analysis which
was developed in the 50s to understand how
pilots and nuclear power plant operators related
to their dashboards and negotiated their work
and I like to call this the Homer Simpson
doughnut because at the end of the day we
are all Homer Simpson trying to make sense
of something that's often complex, and not
really designed for us, and you can see here
this was using the Python DES to better understand
how they used the tools.
So I often work with - I work with fairly
conventional hardware companies and software
companies and the idea of full stack JS makes
them very nervous.
It's like, "Oh, the inmates are running the
asylum", and as folks of the Node Foundation
like to say all 500 Fortune companies are
running Node however this does disrupt long
held beliefs about web devs in this hardware-centric
hierarchy of things.
Oftentimes when I go into the field and interview
JS devs the way that they work is different
than say some folks working "closer to the
metal".
I will tell you a little bit about the differences
that I've found and this is based on qualitative
research.
I do not have large scale demographics to
support this but this is something that I
would urge you all to think about, is thinking
about where can we get, you know, collecting
more demographics about the backgrounds of
your fellow JS devs and quantifying how this
is a more diverse and less conventional community
than we might have previously ascribed to
software or server side development.
That's a first insight and it's probably not
news to anyone here, is that, because there
is no one standard way to become a JavaScript
developer, oftentimes JS devs will acknowledge
this plurality and often I will interview
folks who work in teams together and they
will say, "Yes, like I do things totally different
to him", and this is something that I find
that JS devs are far more comfortable with
than some of their counterparts.
This is a strength.
I would argue that this is something that
we want to acknowledge and see as a strength.
I think it makes for better products, a more
diverse user base.
I've also found, and this is something that
seems a little bit wishy-washy but I want
you to bear with me, I found that, since many
JS devs came of age during desktop-centric
frameworks but have since moved into mobile
and Internet of Things projects, they have
a better conception of code living in the
wild and living in the physical realm, and
I also find that a lot of the JS devs that
I interview have interests in the physical
realm, whether they are knitters or skateboarders
or mountain bikers, and this is something
that is seen not as anathematic to making
software but something that complements it
and this is once again pushing back on the
more immaterial sensibilities of the tradition,
you know, neck beard security developers that
I work with.
That term is used with respect.
The last and maybe most quantifiable and most
important finding that I've made over the
past few years is that JS devs oftentimes
coming from front end work have a better idea
of advocating for the end user and they often
speak with a desire to help others.
I was working on a Internet of Things security
tool this last year and one of the devs said
to me I don't want to make an insecure baby
surveillance device.
And this was very self-aware, I thought, and
also very aware of the impact that one's work
had in the world, but we are at a crossroads
here.
Having a desire to help others is not the
same as actually helping others, and I find
that notions of advocacy are all well and
good but they are often - there's often a
conflict about how to actually put those into
action.
I often say that doing what I do, I often
come to the table when things are already
on fire.
And my goal in the work that I do is helping
you all to smell the smoke, because here's
the thing: I am very sick of empathy as a
corporate buzz word.
Empathy for me is Bill Clinton saying, "I
feel your pain", it's a gratifying thing to
dispense of and it's often, you know, rewarding
to hear it, if someone empathises with you,
but empathy without action is pretty meaningless.
So how do we build advocacy?
If you haven't run across this scene from
the group Indigenous Action I would really
encourage it and I find that we need to think
about our user or end users and the folks
that we work with as accomplices, not allies.
We want to be with them while they use the
products that we build, and that we need - and
that in order to do that we need to build
trust and consent.
No one is going to let us in.
No one is going to trust us until we build
that trust, and we build that trust by walking
alongside them, by acknowledging those diverse
viewpoints and building meaning into our data
gathering.
Oftentimes when I work on developer products,
there's not a really good explanation of who
it's actually for.
This is something that I find that JS devs
have a very low bullshit meter for.
You know, what's the story behind this?
Why am I supposed to use it?
This doesn't make sense with what I'm doing.
I worked on an API this past year that was
developed by folks working in CEE and the
way that the calls were formed just didn't
match JS syntax at all, not that there is
any rhyme or reason to JS syntax but that's
not my field of expertise.
Yes, and this is something I find with developer
tools is that we need to give a reason for
folks to use it.
We need to exculpate the stories and make
a case for it because unless - and there are
some notable exceptions to this, but unless
we make a case for a usable security solution
or for an easily implementable security solution,
it's not going to happen.
I think that in this community our diversity
is our strength but we need ways to understand
our impact and I will repeat my plea to build
more data on demographic diversity; build
more data on who is deploys JS frameworks
at every level of the stack and how it's different,
how workflows are different, and how this
makes for a better impact.
And I think that this is especially important
when our work impacts very vulnerable people.
In the jargon around the Internet of Things,
there's a big buzz word.
If we are going to be building things for
people with limited economic capacity we need
to be more economically aware of how our work
impacts them.
Likewise, as we - did anyone follow the class
action lawsuit?
As we put connected technologies into realms
that we would consider to be very private
we need to make sure that we are protecting
our users' data and notions of empathy and
notions of advocacy are all well and good,
but until - but the rubber hits the road when
we are in this very intimate and necessarily
trustworthy place.
And this is the argument I always make to
my clients: it's that we shouldn't discount
even as generalist or tinkerer devs, if they
cannot rock your security tool then we are
not going to have security, and we need to
invest in design and documentation that does
accommodate a larger span of users, even when
those users are not what we consider to be
traditional devs or traditional implementers
of security.
This is a big task and I think it's something
that will require rebuilding trust not only
amongst new folks coming in but also amongst
the long range users of our products and at
every level of software and hardware development,
so what do we do next?
Where do we go from here?
This will probably be no surprise to you but
I advocate for understanding developer experiences
in every step of the process.
If you are working on a roll your own tool,
put it in front of other people and do this
early and often.
IBM did these studies in the early 1990s that
said that there's a 20/1 ROI on investments
and usability and that ROI number was increased
earlier on in the process.
Usability testing is huge, and bringing your
users in, making a more participatory stance
when developing your tools and their documentation,
and I think that organisations as a whole
can invest in understanding these differences
in values and skill sets.
Because ultimately I hope that we can work
from a standpoint of the ethics of care.
This is a big project that I have been working
on conjointly, but how do we see our work
as caring for our users, not just giving them
something cool to use?
And I think that this is something that we
can bring to our work and that reminds us
of how important what we are doing actually
is.
Lastly, let's work together.
I recently started a programme called UX Night
School bringing design research tools to developers
and designers in the field and I would love
to work with you, so thanks.
[Applause]